[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
yes
are you looking for the best TV shows on
Amazon's Prime video well we have got
you covered with our guide to the best
Amazon Prime video original series and
shows but first let's talk about the
streamer's major tent pulls while the
boys commanded our attention in 2019 the
series has jumped higher on our list
with the release of season two The
Marvelous Mrs maisel kicked up a TV
award storm the year before and these
comedies were not the first of Amazon
Prime videos original shows to Garner
critical and award attention that honor
goes to the groundbreaking transparent
which ended in 2019 after four seasons
and a musical finale other top titles
include fleabag Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan
homecoming good Omens the expanse and
more
let's get to the ABC
adorable
for this guide we set out to list Amazon
Prime's best TV shows to binge watch
that the service has released since
2013. to be included on our list of the
best Amazon Series titles must be fresh
60 or higher on the Tomato Meter with at
least 10 reviews now with all of that
out of the way let's count down the best
shows on Amazon Prime
[Music]
number 10 Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan author
Tom Clancy introduced the character of
Jack Ryan in a series of books before
Ryan headed to the big screen in several
films now the former U.S marine is
featured in an episodic series for the
first time with John Krasinski
portraying Ryan in this Amazon original
Thriller that centers on Ryan as an
up-and-coming CIA analyst he is thrust
into a dangerous field assignment for
the first time and uncovers a pattern in
Terrorist communication that launches
him into the middle of a dangerous
Gambit with a new breed of terrorism
that threatens destruction on a global
scale starring John Krasinski Wendell
Pierce numi rupaz and created by Carlton
cues and Graham Rowland critics say
though not as somatically rich as some
of its geopolitical predecessors Jack
Ryan is a satisfying addition to the
genre buoyed by exceptional action
sequences and a likable cast
foreign
shoot me
I dropped this we all die
because
knock them
those
foreign
I thought you were a bodyguard
number nine the man in the High Castle
this series Loosely based on Philip K
Dick's novel of the same name takes a
look at what the world might look like
had the outcome of World War II turned
out differently in this dystopian
scenario the Axis Powers win the war
leading to the United States being
divided into three parts an area
controlled by the Japanese a
nazi-controlled section and a buffer
zone between the two despite the
oppression A New Hope emerges when films
turn up that seem to show a different
world a woman believes that the films
contain the key to freedom and is
determined to find their mysterious
Guardian starring Alexa Davalos Rupert
Evans Joel De La Fuente Rufus Sewell and
created by Frank spotnitz critics say by
executive producer Ridley Scott The Man
in the High Castle is unlike anything
else on TV within immediately engrossing
plot driven by quickly developed
characters in a fully realized
post-world War II dystopia
I'm joking for power
neither seeks peace they denied in
public
but both men think the petition of the
Americas
was a mistake
they've dropped the bomb before they
won't hesitate to drop it again
fewer dies
without question
in this city would be one of the first
ones to be raised from the map
[Music]
number eight the Underground Railroad
after escaping a Georgia Plantation Cora
boards a train embarking on a harrowing
trip as she seeks true Freedom while
being hunted by a notorious slave
catcher starring tuso embedu Chase W
Dylan Joel Edgerton and created by Barry
Jenkins critics say with a superb
Ensemble and Barry jenkins's singular
eye the Underground Railroad delicately
translates its source material into a
powerfully Humane series that is as
challenging as it is necessary
you can't just leave me here The Station
Agent will be alone I'm sure of it
I wish I could give you more man but
that's all I got
they tied you over for a while
where you come from Miss
Georgia
you a long way from Georgia
must be made of tough stuff
number seven catastrophe
during a business trip in London an
American named Rob meets Sharon an Irish
teacher with whom he shares incredible
chemistry while the two plan to have
some fun with no strings attached things
go awry when Sharon learns that she is
pregnant the unexpected news inspires a
recent acquaintances to try and make it
as a couple despite non-sob
complications that include hailing from
different countries and pregnancy that
is not without risks starring Ashley
Jensen Mark Bonar and Sharon Horgan and
Rob Delaney who both also created the
show critics say catastrophe proves that
there's still a place for simple
romantic comedy on television as long as
the actors have chemistry and the jokes
are laugh out loud funny do you want to
have dinner
[Music]
um
do you want to have dinner
yeah that's why I asked okay
um do you have a wife or anything no no
okay well I'll just I'll write down
you know what that's my work visa so if
you
doesn't matter
okay
great
and I noticed that you took some things
from the bathroom and that's fine but
could you leave the toothpaste I know I
didn't take any teeth oh [ __ ] I did yeah
sorry
small and cute
um so you should probably open a window
which this really stinks in here
number six the expanse
hundreds of years in the future things
are different than what Humanity
expected after humans have colonized the
solar system and Mars has become an
independent military power Rising
tensions between Earth and Mars have put
them on the brink of war against this
backdrop a hardened detective and a
rogue ships Captain come together to
investigate the case of a missing young
woman the investigation leaves him on a
Race Across the solar system that could
expose the greatest conspiracy in human
history starring Stephen straight
Dominic Tipper Wes Chatham and developed
by Mark Fergus and Hawk ottsby critics
say the expanse Blends sci-fi elements
and detective Noir into a visually
compelling hole though it takes a few
episodes for the story to capture
viewers entry
foreign
number five transparent
more has a secret that he really wants
to tell his three adult children who are
so self-absorbed that they don't see
that something has changed for their
divorce girl friendless dad even when he
invites them all to dinner to share his
news somehow the conversation becomes
about them the secret unfolds though
when he comes home and sees his married
daughter getting intimate with her ex
now he knows her secret she knows his
and the dysfunctional family finds
itself exposing one secret after another
starring Jeffrey Tambor Gabby Hoffman
Amy landecker and created by Joey Solway
critics say as much about a change in
television as it is about personal
change transparent raises the bar for
programming with sophistication and
sincere dedication to the human Journey
warts and all hello oh hello
and mercy hi I'm Daphne sparkles
you're here okay oh you don't like it
it's just
it's it's strippery
I'm sorry
um
but it's not right
you need something
elegant
you're Mora
what's your name my name is Marcy what
is your name
my name is Maura
number four the boys
superheroes are often as popular as
celebrities as influential as
politicians and sometimes even as
revered as Gods but that is when they're
using their powers for good what happens
when the heroes go Rogue and start
abusing their powers when it's the
powerless against a super powerful the
boys head out on a heroic quest to
expose the truth about the seven and
Vaught International the multi-billion
dollar conglomerate that manages the
superheroes and covers up their dirty
secrets starring Karl Urban Jack Quade
Anthony Starr Aaron Moriarty and
developed by Eric Kripke critics say
though viewers as mileage may vary the
boys's violent Delights and willingness
to engage in heavy relevant themes are
sure to please those looking for a new
group of anti-heroes to root for
foreign
how do you know the electric could do
the job
the carbon
highly conductive
I saw it on uh
Jimmy Fallon
I would have taken me forever to work
that one out
good job let's get him in the boot
no no I mean what are we what are we
doing with them
well here you just off one of the seven
mate me I you you hit him with a [ __ ]
car
look potato [ __ ] potato we're both in
a lot of trouble no no no we're not it's
he he attacked us okay and you're you're
a Federal Officer you know just just
call us the [ __ ] FBI
yeah okay so look technically I'm not a
fed
what
then who the [ __ ] are you
number three small ax
based on the real life experiences of
London's West Indian Community between
1969 and 1982. small ax goes right for
the heart revealing how a caring
Community comes together and creates its
own space to thrive starring John boyega
Amara J Saint abean Leticia Wright and
created by Steve McQueen critics say
under Steve McQueen's deaf Direction
small acts Chronicles a community's joy
in pain with the epic sweep of a
televisual masterpiece
if me I teach you the after you have
compensation for me time
you understand
got 30 Pence
30 Pence
that is satisfactory for a few pointers
now walk
Victoria edman
a slow it down weeds no it's much
luckily star trooper hunting in Jedi you
got to be the Jedi doing the haunting of
the Storm Trooper blinking talking about
signing in rocks violin man what are you
blinking talking about no [ __ ] you
Dennis
I know no one teaching in my life a mum
or dad brother or sister no one my whole
life
I had nobody
it's only ramping with your bridging
the truth
I can't know how deep European
you're the real thing man no hyping
but I always kept eyes off you
anyways
it's salami
Christmas song and my mother puts on a
serious spread you wanna come start with
the Jamaican Germany I don't like
Christmas what
not mild chicken rice and peas Wars
potato stuffing all right all right as
long as you quite your beak about it
you'll go yeah
number two flea bag
a dry-witted woman known as fleabag has
no filter as she navigates life and love
in London while trying to cope with
tragedy the angry grief riddled woman
tries to heal while rejecting anyone who
tries to help her but fleabag continues
to keep up her bravado through it all
comic actress Phoebe Waller Bridge stars
as the titular character on the series
which is based on Waller Bridge's 2013
one woman show of the same name starring
Ben Aldridge CNN Clifford and Phoebe
Waller Bridge who also created the show
critics say clever and viciously funny
fleabag is a touching wildly inventive
comedy about a complicated young woman
navigating the aftermath of trauma
foreign
hey
no Anthony no that is exactly what she
asked for no it's not we want
compensation Claire I've got two
important meetings and I look like a
pencil no don't blame me for your bad
choices
Harris and everything
oh
what
hair is everything
we wish it wasn't so we could actually
think about something else occasionally
but it is
the difference between a good day and a
bad day we're meant to think that it's a
symbol of power that is a symbol of
fertility some people are exploited for
it and it pays your [ __ ] bills hair
is everything Anthony
show her the reference
Claudia
bring me the bin
if you want to change your life change
your life
it's not going to happen in here
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
homecoming
stories surrounding the mysterious Geist
group and unconventional wellness
company and it's equally unorthodox
program the homecoming initiative
starring Julia Roberts Janelle Monae
Stefan James and created by Ellie
Horowitz and Micah Bloomberg critics say
an impressive small screen debut for
Julia Roberts homecoming balances its
haunting mystery with a frenetic
sensibility that grips and doesn't let
go okay so how soon do you think you
might have that for me have what the
data Heidi you're you're pushing on that
right absolutely yeah and I think we
need to be surgically precise in this
everything these guys remember yes
okay absolutely I just if you can just
give me one sec
um I just had a session actually with uh
Walter Cruz he is a great candidate
really really happy I don't have a lot
of time like at the airport in like 32
minutes I'll be quick I was just
thinking in terms of being granular as
you said and deliberate that perhaps we
could take a more holistic approach to
the initial stages of the treatment
holistic well I feel like we're just
kind of throwing them into the process
without developing much of a
relationship I'm gonna stop you there
okay okay what we're seeking here Heidi
is information not relationships not
Rapport whatever these men are holding
on to that's exactly what we need to
know now I get that I just in terms of
okay well based on what you just said
you don't so I need you to 180 on this
okay
[Music]
yeah okay I just was thinking of in
Terms again I say things like holistic
I don't even know what they would do we
need real proof of concept here just a
house updated a drop of the
Appropriations people so they shut their
mouth stop for barricading and open up
the approval process that's our goal
understood and before we get to number
one here are some more honorable
mentions
Hunters
Nazi Hunters discover hundreds of
high-ranking Nazi officials in 1977 New
York City conspiring to create a fourth
Reich in the United States the hunters
set out to bring the Nazis to Justice
and thwart their new genocidal plans
starring Al Pacino Logan Lerman jerika
Hinton and created by David whale
critics say propelled by a strong cast
an even stronger sense of justice
Hunters is stylish for a season doesn't
always hit the mark but when it does it
strikes pulpy Peter
hello God
now we can make this interrogation
painless
are painful
depends on you
what do you think
let me ask you
who are you communicating with
what are you Broadcasting
lullabies for the children
broadcast Symphonies too
or press
even Abba when he thinks
I gave away freebies sometimes to the
first caller
okay Joe
I think we're ready
the ears are the most sensitive part of
the body
they control balance and bodily function
no cow
last chance
good Omens
this fantasy series sees fussy Angel
aziraphal and loose living demon Crowley
team up to form an unlikely Duo the two
have become overly fond of life on Earth
and they're forced into forming an
alliance in an attempt to stop the
approaching Armageddon but to do that
they have to find the missing Antichrist
an 11 year old boy who is unaware that
he is meant to bring the end of days
upon Humanity starring Michael Sheen
David Tennant Jon Hamm and created by
Neil Gaiman critics say a smorgasbord of
heavenly imagery and irreverent hilarity
good Omens works thanks to Michael Sheen
and David Tennant's very nearly holy or
maybe Unholy chemistry though at only
six episodes It's a rare adaptation that
may have benefited from being a little
less faithful to the good book
oh that went down like a lead balloon
sorry what was that
I said well that went down like a lead
balloon
yes yes
it did rather
a bit of an overreaction if you ask me
first offensive
I can't see what's so bad about knowing
the difference between good and evil
anyway
oh it must be bad
crawling crawling
otherwise
you wouldn't have tempted them into it
uh they just said get up there and make
some trouble well obviously you're a
demon it's what you do
not very subtle of the almighty though
fruit tree in the middle of a garden
where they don't touch silence put it on
the top of a high mountain
or on the moon
would you wonder what God's really
planning
and finally number one The Marvelous Mrs
maisel in the late 1950s Miriam Midge
maisel has everything she has ever
wanted the perfect husband two kids and
an elegant apartment on New York's Upper
West Side her seemingly idyllic life
takes a surprising turn when she
discovers a hidden talent that she
didn't previously know she had stand up
comedy this Revelation changes her life
forever as she begins a journey that
takes her from her comfortable life on
the upper west side through the cafes
and nightclubs of Greenwich Village as
she makes her way through the city's
comedy industry on a path that could
ultimately lead her to a spot on The
Tonight Show couch starring Rachel
Brosnahan Michael ziegan Alex Borstein
Tony Shalhoub and created by Amy Sherman
Palladino critics say The Marvelous Mrs
maisel is an upbeat addition to Amazon's
original offerings propelled by a
playful yet poignant performance by
Rachel Brosnahan
so my life's completely fell apart today
did I mention that my husband left me
okay all right but did I mention that he
left me for his secretary
she's 21 and dumb as a Brillo pen and
I'm not naive I know that men like
stupid girls right but I thought Joel
wanted more than stupid I thought he
wanted spontaneity
he whipped I thought he wanted to be
challenged you know what I mean uh you
two are gonna be together forever
great wife I was fun I planned theme
nights I dressed in costumes I gave him
kids a boy and a girl and yes our little
girl is looking more and more like
Winston Churchill every day you know
with big Yalta head but that's not a
reason to leave right
really really after what I just said
about the bathroom
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]